new motivation
watch a top ten with believe nation hey
it's Nina Carmichael this channel is
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you're
watching this video because you know
there's more inside you to your genius
so get ready to raise your standard with
Evan Carmichael here's our take on his
top ten rules for success volume 10
okay let's kick it out with rule number
one take the risk most people are so
afraid of losing that they don't even
try you'd rather stay average because
going for greatness means you might fail
adopt this mindset it's better to know
and to fail than not to know all of your
heroes failed on their path to success
and if you are unwilling to risk failure
for greatness
you will stay on your exact same path
that you're on right now so I was
recently faced with an impossible choice
where I didn't know the outcome where
two people who I respected told me
opposite bits of advice and it was
around splitting up my youtube channel I
have had my youtube channel I mean one
for over 10 years it's crazy ten years
of creating content I got up to making
three videos a day on my main channel I
get on a call with Matt Gillen who's one
of four people in the world who they
gave me advice on YouTube I would really
strongly deeply think about it I respect
him and three of the people that much
and he told me Evan you need to split up
your channel Evan doing three videos a
day on the same channel hurts you and
you should split it up into multiple
channels that was an impossible choice I
mean for me was it was scary it was
difficult I don't know the outcome so I
asked some other friends of mine
somebody else in the top forum and he
says that is the biggest mistake you
could make don't do it it's a huge
mistake for your channel it'll hold you
back so now what do I do
there's four people in the world whose
opinions I respect and trust on this one
topic and two of them are giving me
exact opposite advice
what do I do for me the decision was
easy the action was difficult it was
tough but we do tough things right we're
entrepreneurs here's my decision-making
process
I would rather no one fail than not know
going my current course of making 3
videos a day on one channel I know what
that looks like I'm liking my success
I'm liking my growth but splitting up my
channels and going down to one video a
day on my main channel I didn't know if
they would work and if I don't try I'll
never know so even though one person I
really respect tells me it's the biggest
mistake of my life
it may be it may be the worst decision
that I ever make in my youtube career
but I won't know unless I try and would
rather live my life without regrets
knowing that I got the information
instead of being afraid to act and so I
split it up and listen right now it's
actually not working right now the views
on my main channel are down the
subscribers on my main channel are down
the amount of money I make for our main
channel is down and my other channels
like this one haven't grown enough to
combat it
to replace it what I'm still soldiering
on I'm still continuing down this path
now if it's a year and it's still the
same thing ok maybe I have to go back to
my old strategy but at least I would
know and so you can look at that and say
well you lost all that opportunity yeah
I made a mistake but I'd rather know and
fail than not know because if you only
take safe bets if you only take the bets
that you know you're gonna win it with a
hundred percent certainty then you play
small for life then you're only gonna
take on the projects that there's zero
risk of failure right which means you
stay in this tiny circle I don't want to
live in a tiny circle I want to change
the world I want to have a huge impact
that comes with a great deal of failure
just like all your heroes ruined there
were to be impatience with yourself you
need to be more impatient with yourself
but patient with the results flip it
most people are impatient with the
results you want the money right now you
want the customers right now you want
the views right now you want the
subscribers right now
but you're patient with yourself you let
yourself off the hook all the time
you procrastinate and don't put in 100%
effort that needs to change flip it be
more patient with the results and
impatient with yourself because if
you're impatient with yourself if you
domained 100% effort of yourself every
single day I guarantee you the results
will come rule number three act now the
decisions that you make when you're
feeling bold or actually the right ones
for you and your head starts talking you
down from doing them when you're feeling
bold unstoppable confident powerful and
you make a decision you make a choice
you say I'm gonna go off and do this
thing that is actually the best thing
that you need to go off and do you have
to listen to it you have to take that
jump otherwise you will still be in the
same spot you are currently in right now
five years from today so I just came
back from doing a tour 90 day tour 23
different cities it all started because
I was walking down the street on a warm
summer day last year and I decided I'm
gonna take Nina my wife to every city in
North America with a million-plus people
crazy go alright my next evolution the
next is leap the next jump every city
North America with my wife let's go and
then your head gets in the way then your
head starts thinking well how many
cities are there how do we plan for this
Nina has a full-time job how are you
gonna make it all work what's the time
I'm gonna be your default first step
needs to be action instead of thinking
what most of us will do as soon as you
come with an idea is you go home and you
think and you plan and you ponder and
you strategize and you think and you use
all of your creative bold confident
energy into planning the problem is you
wake up the next day a different person
you wake up the next day thinking I
can't do that I can't go to every city
in North America with million-plus
people I can't do this I can't do that
you come up with all the reasons that
are logical that are practical as to why
you can no longer do that thing you were
feeling bold and confident yesterday but
today you can't do it that's why your
default first step needs to be action
use that bold creative powerful energy
into action into committing yourself to
doing something and taking what I call
the first two percent the two percent
difference that means don't go home and
plan your way to hitting 100 percent of
your goal immediately take the first 2%
action to move a tiny bit closer to your
goal and so I said I'm gonna take my
wife Nina every city in North America
and pose people great what's my first
step not researching how many cities not
trying to figure out how Nina's gonna
quit her job not any of that stuff not
planning not strategizing it's this
weekend we're gonna go to Boston because
I knew Boston had a million-plus people
and I knew Nina hadn't been there yet so
we're gonna go to Boston it was actually
the wrong plan it wasn't the closest
city I thought it was the closest city
but there's multiple cities that are
closer but the imperfect plan that you
act on is better than the perfect plan
that you sit on and never deal anything
about and so we went to Boston that
weekend it was a Wednesday afternoon I
decided by Friday night we were leaving
and driving the Boston action this is
the thing that most people are missing
you don't have enough action the 2%
difference stop planning to 100% and
figure out what the smallest possible
simplest version of doing that thing is
right now immediately today rule number
four don't take no for an answer
swap your nose for not yet no it's so
final no means it's over there's no path
back right it's a no it's final it's
over finish line we're done right not
yet means there's still the Scylla path
and I think for any entrepreneur part of
what we're doing is so visionary it's so
different it's so new there's gonna be a
lot of people who don't agree with what
you're doing because you're challenging
the status quo because you're trying to
do something that hasn't been done
before and there's a lot of people who
like the way that is happening right now
and so most people make decisions from
their brain just the logical practical
side of their brain we're entrepreneurs
what we do best is we make decisions
from our heart and so the brain can only
imagine a world that currently exists
right it's logical practical is what
currently exists where your heart can
create something brand new
that hasn't existed yet before yet and
so you gotta turn the nose when somebody
says no that's not going to happen
you're never gonna make it you're not
good enough you don't have the resources
you don't have the knowledge you don't
have the connections you don't come from
the right family you're not born in the
right country right whatever that I know
is just turn it into not yet just wait
just watch me
I'm coming also I feel more confidence
check out our 254 series it's free the
link to join is in the description below
surround yourself with greatness if you
want to be more confident you need to
surround yourself with things that make
you feel confident find whatever the
smallest first step is and in the
smallest next step is and continue to
build those steps and when you look back
you'll have realized that you made it's
a pretty significant progress rise above
pain if you want to be a successful
entrepreneur you're going to have to
deal with a lot of pain there will be a
moment when you feel like things just
can't get any worse you're at the bottom
and then how life hits you in the face
and that moment will define you if
you're gonna quit and give up go back to
having a job or you're gonna learn to
rise above and start having success as
an entrepreneur the strategy that I like
to use is it's the best you take
whatever negative situation you're in
whatever that thing that feels
overwhelming all-consuming impossible to
deal with and you tell yourself this is
the best this thing is happening to me
right now is the best this is my chance
to show myself and the world what I made
up it's the best and in actuality it is
the best because we very rarely get
chances to show ourselves what we're
made of we very rarely actually put
ourselves into these situations where we
get hit in the face rule number six make
product you love making a product that
people love starts with you making
something that you love really think
about it would you buy from you would
you subscribe to you would you comment
and tell your friends
you in our rush to get rich to make
money we push products out that we don't
love and if you don't love them people
around you won't love them either so
look at my youtube channel as an example
I love my youtube channel I make my
youtube channel for myself I learn it's
selfish it's for me the top 10 rules
videos the ants wrestle video is the
content that I bring together I need it
it's my education I love my channel I
would share my channel with other people
if I saw my channel and I wasn't
Creighton I'd be the first thing that I
subscribe to it would be much watch
YouTube for me I need it and if you guys
didn't like it I would still create it
for myself it wouldn't have as much
editing and fancy effects and all that
stuff but I would still do it because I
need it for me I make it for myself
selfishly and then I share it with you
guys and thankfully you guys like enough
that I can turn the business from it and
continue to hire teamm and create more
content and pump more stuff out but as
much as I think that my channel still
needs to get better and grow and improve
and I still suck and I need to
continuously get better at the work that
I do I think my channel deserves a Nobel
Peace Prize like I think my channel is
amazing and you have to love what you do
you have to feel like the thing that
you're doing yes can always get better
but is really solving a problem your
product your service what you create
your expertise solves a problem you know
that it's genuinely helping people if
you don't have that belief you're never
gonna win rule number 7 used to
knowledge it to your advantage
there are three ways to use technology
and most people pick the one method that
costs them money you can be entertained
you can be educated and you can create
entertained educated create the first
one costs you money entertainment the
second one is an investment education
and the third one makes you money create
the answer isn't to dump your phone and
delete all social media it's to use
these insanely powerful tools to help
you make money and achieve your goals so
what I want you to do is now evaluate
how are you using technology
and where does the fall until illustrate
categories entertain educate and create
I'll use me as an example I'll go first
you go next so for me let me look at
YouTube as an example great number one
entertain very little the only
entertainment content that I consume on
YouTube is gonna be one music which is
really more just getting my state into
an energetic positive one and two on the
weekends League of Legends watching my
team TSM hopefully carry the day other
than that I don't spend any time on
entertainment content people send me
links to videos if Alex comes in and
wants to show me some silly videos like
dude I'm working I don't want to be
entertained right now I got stuff to do
I want to go crush it on my goals on my
dreams I got a lot that I need to get
done today don't send me this stuff to
educate I use YouTube a lot YouTube is
my number one source for education more
than books more than podcasts more than
anything else conferences anything
YouTube is where I learn video content
is where I learn most of my time spent
on YouTube is researching and reviewing
video clips that I am personally getting
inspired by that then I want to share
with you if I am making a video that I'm
sharing with you on any of my channels
it's because I have learned something
from them so I'm spending most of my
time on YouTube being educated and then
number three is creating and creating a
lot we're doing three videos a day
across my seven channels so I'm creating
so I'm using YouTube not just as a way
that cost me money right that I have to
go spend money to buy something but I'm
using it to invest into myself as well
as to create content and then generates
a return as I can build a business
around it rule number eight raise your
standards
expecting excellence starts with you
expecting excellence from yourself
people want to work for people who they
aspire to be like if someone excellent
is working for you but they have higher
standards than you do they will
eventually leave you
your company's limit is your standards
so I look at Alex as an example who
helps me run Toronto dance salsa I
invest into the company and number of
years ago I became the hundred percent
owner in it and then I'm training Alex
to run it one of the things that Alex
had any she was was showing up on time
we had low standards for himself of
being on time if you said be here at ten
o'clock he would be here at ten fifteen
or ten twenty and that just became what
he was known for everybody knew alex is
the guy who didn't follow through who
came late the things and that was Alex
great some people are willing to put up
with it
some people will tolerate it because
they like his energy his enthusiasm his
fun his bravado they like it and they
have low standards for themselves by
high achievers people who have high
standards that would drive them nuts and
people would leave the business people
would not want to work with them people
would want to go somewhere else because
their standards are higher than the
person that they're supposed to be
working for nobody wants to be in a
situation you do not want to work for
somebody who has lower standards than
you do and so the challenge became Alex
we need to raise your standards you need
to start showing up not just on time but
early for him now it's ten minutes early
so if we said is gonna be here at 10:00
that means you're there at 9:50 you're
there at 10:00 to 10:00 you have to be
so you're late if you show by 10 o'clock
for Alex him as his own standards that
somebody else if you're showing up at 10
o'clock and you say you're gonna be
there at 10 o'clock he's late to himself
that's a starting point and as his
standards have risen so have the people
underneath his team were willing to
follow him as your standards rise as you
care more about yourself in what you're
doing and what you will no longer accept
and tolerate then the people who are
working for you their standards rise as
well and you're able to now attract a
much wider pool because they want to
level up people want to be around you
yes for your mission but they want to
level up with your responsibility to
help people level up
and so if you're only at this point as
soon as somebody gets here they're
leaving but as you can go here then you
can attract a lot of people underneath
who want to level up and they're gonna
learn from you not just the knowledge
but the ability is the mindset the
hustle the energy the drive that you
pour into your business will be an
inspiration to other people when you
raise your own standards rule number
nine stop compared to others you need to
stop judging your version of balance
against someone else's I think this is
something that plagues at least the
North American culture we're constantly
comparing what makes us happy against
somebody else's likes you have a version
of balance you have a version of
happiness you have a version of passion
it's different for everybody
I can't judge you for what you're doing
the only test is are you proud of
yourself do your actions map to your
ambitions is what's in your calendar a
reflection of what will make you happy
and I think as soon as you can get into
your own head as soon as you can
understand what happiness and balance
and success looks like for you and stop
comparing it against somebody else's
version in your life for an Instagram
that's when you can actually go off and
find the success you're after and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is tie yourself worth
to the effort you need to tie yourself
worth to the effort not the results if
you tie your self-worth to the results
to achieving your goals then you'll only
take on things that you think you have a
high chance of winning at you'll
constantly quit on your big goals and
only go after the small ones tie
yourself for two trying to the effort to
doing it when it's hard make yourself
proud with the effort that you put in
not just when you win but if you keep
getting up every day and putting in
effort that you are proud of you will
Wayne on a level that you never thought
was possible people are afraid of
selling you're afraid you're gonna get
rejected you're afraid you're gonna be
seen as a greedy slimy selfish
salesperson the reality though is you
offer a fantastic product or service you
can help people and if you can't sell to
them they may never get the help that
they so desperately need you can do
sales in an ethical way that are true
too
your core values you must your business
and your customers depend on it so I
used to have a big aversion to selling I
used to think you know you have to have
a big ego to do I didn't want to rip
people off I didn't want people to think
that I was trying to you know squeeze
them out of money I didn't want to get
rejected all of the typical fears that I
think people have when they get into
sales and I still don't use sales as my
primary tactic to go out and get
business but when you see an opportunity
to help somebody you have to give them
your best effort to help them and I had
to get more into sales because I saw
entrepreneurs who were struggling who
were not getting the help that they
needed and I knew it can help them but I
wasn't really passionate about selling
what I was selling I was constantly
worried and living in fear and when you
live in fear you don't make smart
decisions and I got more into it because
I saw people who were failing who who
should have used my help who I could
have helped and I didn't step up and
then they failed and they went out of
business and they made bad mistakes I
own that that's my response that was my
fault I could have helped and I didn't I
should have sold myself harder and I
didn't and I let everybody down
I let them down I let myself down and in
a broader sense I let my family down my
community down I have responsibility to
grow this business and to help more
people and that involves me selling
myself so fast forward to today I had
two guys in my morning show who wanted
to be thought leaders they wanted to
have books they went to be speakers they
wanted to be at the front of the room
they wanted to build their social media
accounts and profiles they wanted to be
seen recognizes experts in their
industries thought leaders I do a
workshop twice a year in Toronto for
three days helping people make money as
thought leaders and I break down my
exact strategies how we're going on
YouTube how are going Instagram what
your content strategy how to make videos
how to come up with ideas how to create
content how to win how to get speaking
gigs how to get a book deal all of it be
me be the Evan Carmichael of your
industry I break down how to do it but
not just a break down not just hey let's
sit in the room and learn from ideas
we're gonna work with you to do it I
take 15 people twice a year and I work
through exactly how to do it and
you're taking your phone out and you're
making content you're making videos and
I'm gonna be sitting there talking to
you what helping you do it then you get
in front of the camera and you have to
make a video and I'm gonna be behind the
camera with my team telling you nope
nope again do it again and say it like
this nope not quiet nope keep going a
lot of personalized one-on-one
mentorship if you want to be a thought
leader it's among the best training in
the world you need to do it if you have
the budget you can make the time free
you should come out and do it
and some talking to these two people who
want to be thought leaders and I have
the knowledge and I have the training to
help them I think that three-day event
should be something that they at least
are aware of and so with one of them I
walk through the entire process of what
I cover in the event and I'm trying to
do it in a way that brings them value
obviously and then the other one I
quickly mentioned it and then followed
up in the DM on Instagram and say hey
here's the event I think it'd be good
for you
maybe they come maybe they don't come
maybe some of them feel like they're
being sold to I don't think so because
it was when it's genuine when they can
feel your passion and love and energy
and care and desire to help them that's
what breaks through if you don't
actually care about the end consumer if
you see somebody coming to the oh that
person's my next car that person is my
next suit that person is my next XYZ
right my next watch if that's the
mindset in attitude then they won't feel
the care they're gonna feel like they're
being sold to and being ripped off but
when you have the energy compassion
heart to help and you know that this is
the thing that they should do I think
it's your responsibility to go off and
tell them about it when you believe in
what you're selling and when you believe
that is actually the right thing for
that person it's your responsibility to
sell it
if you wanna see Evans top 50 rules
video go click on the link right next to
me
continue to believe and we will see you
there the people who win work the
hardest because they love what they do I
hate spending money till on making money
if you do not have money